comme d'hab' pour ses vidéos live avant
c'est un tout petit peu parce que je
vais vérifier que le truc et bien et
bien démarré sur sur twitter en live
parce que sinon c'est un peu ridicule ce
qu'aujourd'hui on va aller on va on va
résoudre des tactiques ensemble c'est
que vous avez bien et b la dernière fois
ça vous avez plus et moi aussi ça
m'avait plu
donc en fait on était heureux et pour un
petit peu varié puisque on n'a pas mal
joué en live avec les arénas des autres
semaines fallu beaucoup de gens live là
pour ceux qui auraient mérité du coup ça
comptera pas même pour ceux qui
regardent en là il va y avoir la sinne
que phil cap à partir de samedi sur la
chaîne vide stream
donc il ya plein de choses il ya plein
plein plein de choses et un petit peu de
tactique s'entraîner un petit peu ça va
pas nous faire de mal que ce soit vous à
moi donc genre c'est le premier exercice
de laisser les gens arriver et avoir ce
qu'il faut alors attendez on a on a les
blancs aucun n'a les blancs et les vélos
pions va par là faut que je fasse gaffe
à ne pas faire de clic droit
donc le mec veut faire dames en 2 coups
intéressants
ce qui est sûr c'est que est-ce qu'on
peut gagner
ok effet dame sur échec donc de toutes
façons on va on va pas pouvoir
donc ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'on
arrête son pion alors lui mettre en
échec en e2 ça me paraît irréaliste que
cavalia cavaliers à 4g deux cavaliers
ces trois géants dames échec
donc c'est pas possible donc j'imagine
que le premier coup soit être cavaliers
des cinq échecs sur cavaliers des cinq
échecs si vous me suivez
si vous êtes là la case la plus logique
pour le roi c'est de venir en f3 et là
moi je ferai un petit coup de fouine sur
walf 3 je ferai un petit coup de fouine
alors pourquoi je dis f3 on suivait moi
les mecs sains j'espère que vous me
suivez
mais quand le roi mieux en f3 pourquoi
par rapport aux cavaliers en d5 jeu
mèneront à f3 parce que j'ai envie de me
mettre en diagonale par rapport aux
cavaliers pour pas vous prendre des
chèques et donc après wife 3 je vous ai
un petit peu aidés
vous allez me dire ce que vous allez
faire mais moi je vais mettre mes
lunettes parce que je suis un professeur
sérieux j'espère que vous aimez bien
donc à vous de réfléchir j'ai expliqué
le maximum que je pouvais pour pas vous
donner la réponse est pour vous donner
des petites pistes de réflexion
maintenant à vous de voir
je laisse un peu le chat arrivé au
passage n ya des gens dans le chat donc
ça arrive ça arrive petit à petit effet
voir si on est sur le seul truc tu fais
comme l'aura peut-être en replay 1 qui
ont déjà résolu l'an tout cas nous en
live on est bloqué à cavaliers des cinq
échecs 3f 3 on ne trouve pas mais on va
bien finir par trouver en est là on
s'entraîne on échoue vous êtes chauds ou
pas d'ailleurs
c'est lucette gautier à jour amène le
cavalier sur échec et puis c'est tout
est ce que vous êtes chaud parce qu'il
ya ces canards qui est 100 et soyons du
show dont le tchad ya une bonne mère qui
est chaud et puis j'ai l'impression
qu'ils se sont refroidies quoi ils se
sont beaucoup trop compliqué
je n'écris plus sur le tchat je refuse
d'écrire sur ce chat jour là pour voir
si peut-être mettre un petit à mettre un
petit hosting avec la chaîne bitstream
aussi
mais ce beau pays je suis pas chaud et
très froid quoi et je met un petit
hosting je fais avec le portable
maintenant
bon
le stream vous héberge pour 17
spectateurs si vous êtes sûr regarder
via bitstream
j'ai mis le chat sur le portable mais
c'est off qui arrive donc les mécontents
d'un cavalier des cinq échec 3-3 comment
vous résolvez ça parce que là on est mal
aimée cas pour le moment on n'a pas
d'eau on n'a pas de solution on est on
est perdu quoi on sait pas quoi faire on
peut plus avancer on est perdu dans dans
un univers on est on est dans un trou
noir avait des mecs
personne ne nous en sort sauvez-nous
quoi sauver nous du trou noir
il ya des gens qui réfléchissent dans ce
chat qu'est ce qu'est ce que c'est que
ce chat ou c'est le chat le plus
feignants du du monde qu'est ce que
c'est que ce chat les mecs
allez on se chauffe un allez allez allez
allez y les coins il est 20 heures
20h03 allez on se laisse jusqu'à 20h05
allez on se laisse deux minutes on le
réseau
et on ne résout allez les mecs
on peut le faire tous ensemble à l'esat
de baisse résoudre à cet exercice cette
baisse il peut le résoudre
parce que là on n'en peut plus m
peut-être que moi je n'ai pas la réponse
je ne sais pas c'est à vous de ta vous
de trouver comment on arrête ce pion g
qui court tout est rétif aux cèpes the
best pour nous aider afin d'envoyer un
cavalier des cinq échecs ont saisi pour
attraper le pion airways 3 ici j'ai les
noirs je gagne si les blancs je gagne le
pion il veut faire g2g 1 et d'un échec
et on n'a pas le temps de faire h6 parce
qu'il fait j'ai deux ont fait htc g1
dame échec et on gagne plus on perd il
faut il faut marc et espions g et les
mecs c'est un dangereux criminel
enfin vous comment vous voulez arrêter à
enlever le quart et n'ont eu de cesse de
baisse le problème c'est sûr qu'il va
liés à la 4g deux cavaliers c3g 1 dames
échec
pas le temps monsieur pop moby 5002 et
nous dit je suis débutant voire très
débutants mais je dirais poussé le roi
en d4 pour préparer le cheval arrivant
de trois ans même si du fait roi des
quatre îles fait g2 qui fait qu'il y ait
des 5
il te fait j'ai un dame est ton cheval
n'a pas le temps arrive en 2 3 enfin
normalement jeudi roi des 4 kg de
truites et des cinq échecs qui fait roi
f3 pardon cavaliers 3 et géant dames et
a pas le temps de d'arrivée en 3 me dire
tu étais pas arrivés à temps il te
manque un temps
heureusement que crystal et la coiffe
cristal merci donc à aider cinq échecs
le roi lion air froid est là en fait on
va faire le coup de fouine de cryptage
on va faire cavalier e 3 du coup le roi
il va se mettre en retrait quand ils
font g1 dame sait plus sur échec
on va faire à vis ici vont faire j'ai
deux on va faire achètent ils vont faire
g1 et on va pouvoir faire
ashwin dame pas pour tout le monde a
bien compris on va prendre le temps
quand même on va pas aller trop vite
ça va tout le monde j'avais fait que
tout soit bien de sonner en place en
mairie où c'est très fin et c'était fin
alors là le mec nous a fait roi c5
alors il ya ces deux fous là il ya ce
vis-à-vis des fous et on a quand même
deux tours attaqué nettement pour le
moment je sais pas
pour faire nul c'est facile mais il doit
falloir gagner parce que si on veut
faire du long fait juste vous prend 1,6
en échange tout donc ça doit aller
peut-être des gens qui vont trouver plus
vite que moi dans dans le chat un an ni
x 3m est fou à 3 est quand même beaucoup
de questions encore un bobby fischer il
ya énormément de questions après x 3
genres la première question que je me
pose après fou à 3 c'est fou c'est en
fait c'est le premier truc que je me
suis demandé est fou c'est bien le truc
ça menace le fou pour peut-être je vois
pas des trucs parce que je suis pas fou
j'ai mis toute la force que j'avais hier
et lundi et dans tous les trucs que j'ai
fait donc j'y crois pas que je sais pas
trop mais bon fois à trois pouces et 1
c'est un premier problème on n'hésite
pas à y réfléchir je vais regarder les
autres propositions du tchat et cdh un
peu modérer tout ça et peut-être
quelqu'un aura la bonne réponse alors
tour f k démunis qui ajuste vous prend
f4 tour h4 il ya juste français
alors fois trois fous c'est un tour b3
il va te faire [ __ ] en a trois mais tu
auras rien gagné au final
du coup il faudrait jouer tour b1 et
avoir à peu près la même chose pour le
moment j'ai pas trouvé un
on peut aussi faire tourbe et trois
français un tour ces trois mais bon ça
une pareille grand chose juste
l'impression qu'on doit je vois pas
comment immatériel dans le x 3 n'est pas
enfermé à bobby fischer 2
honnêtement je n'en sais rien je sache
totalement honnête j'ai vraiment besoin
de vous parce que je sèche totalement je
vais y que ça va être fou à trois aussi
parce qu'en fait je vois rien d'autre de
base mais ok c'est pas mal ce que dit
gros chat alors bush à une ou dix fois 3
alors sur x 3 us hifu j'ai cet échec et
mais bon donc fois trois fous série new
tourbe et deux échecs pas mal et puis on
va faire tour ces deux alors ça veut
dire que tourbe et deux échecs il va
devoir faire roi c4 ok il va y avoir
tour ces deux échecs il va devoir faire
roi b3 on va faire tout reprend ses
seins il va faire froid prend à trois et
on va faire tour ces trois échecs
allez je suis assez d'accord et gros
chat mais surtout à trois arrêts de
trucs à regarder un est aussi fou j'ai
cet échec il faut un échec je vous fais
roi f4 et qu'on ferait une découverte
allez on part pour foix iii les mecs ont
fait confiance à crouch a donc poussé un
seul coup de défense est ce qu'on avait
vu tomber deux échecs de groucha roi c4
seul coup seule case tour ces deux
échecs roi b3 seul coup faire la double
attaque tout reprend c'est un art on
apprend à 3 seul coup pour ses trois
échecs double attaque roi b4 et tour
premiers froids bien joué au chat et on
a gagné une pièce suivant très haut
blanc ou la personne en partie distrait
pas longtemps
je serais même pas du tout je jouerai
tempo personnes
pierre runique a valu à eux quatre alors
l'hésitation aller où elle est entre le
cavalier e 4 de bobby fischer mais
aurait peut-être qu'à valider cette qui
protège donc à peut-être mieux
pour empêcher toute défense on sent
aussi cher qui va un peu vite dans les
tactiques n'hésite pas à pas à te poser
un petit peu un c'est important de se
poser et bien vérifier ok bobby fischer
qui a trouvé ont fait carré l'épreuve 5
en premier donc on menace cavalier e 4
et sur pions français 3 on va revenir en
g4 et on va jouer sur le clouage du
cavalier f6 ok ça va pour tout le monde
alors que ça suivant un gland un grand
classique du rire allez aucune aucune
aide
c'est un grand classique du rire
et on a aussi des réponses dans le chatt
là bas du damage 7c on a des bonnes
réponses de partout damages cet échec
roy prend à vii forcé tour cette double
échec donc les noirs n'avaient pas le
temps de faire d'alger de maths et tour
à vii matt hockey suivant une petite
finale j'aime bien ça un joli joli joli
je vous laisse chercher
mais ce que la bonne réponse
je pensais avoir ma lorsque vous ce que
vous trouvez
alors déjà à bobby fischer première
chose c'est qu'à tulle irois france et 4
est ce que ces forces et on reprend ses
quatre sur ces 4
allez il faut des lignes plus concrète
parce que ces quatre français qui a déjà
fait un c4 peut-être je suis roi des
quatre personnes alors robbie keane ou
10 e 7 noeuds 7 sur 27 tours à huit mais
surtout ravi tu veux ou huit dames
grauby grosbill ou grauby n'ont eu cette
parole louis 10 tours eux deux ces
quatre échecs mais est ce que le mec va
te faire on reprend ses quatre jeux pas
même chose que pour vous et qui chargent
de te fait roi des 4
j'ai raison concède un petit peu dans le
chat alors max savy e7 retour eu de
fouilles bc3 ces quatre fous à 6 échecs
roux tour emprise ok donc première
variante qu'on a c'est eux cette tour eu
deux fous b cet échec croise et 4 x 6
mais il ya peut-être une deuxième
défense pour les noirs sur recettes
alors si on fait c'est qu'à trois des
quatre sets y aura toujours tour de les
mecs sains et la tour viendra à stopper
une pions mais moi j'aime bien cette
vente de cette tour deux foulées cet
échec le roi il pourra pas venir sur la
colonne eux parce que ra8 dame et la
tourelle couvrira plus et si l'on a bien
en c4 on enfilera avec x 6 faut suivre
j'essaie de faire avec la souris donc du
coup e set mais peut-être ont fait pas
tout re de peut-être une autre défense
en fait c'est défendre un peu plus
violemment encore même les mecs
allez on se bat on défend pas assez
résistant pour le moment c'est un
exercice qu'on vous compterez juste une
collante erreur tactique vous compterez
juste mais moi je vous le comte faut
vous ne résistez pas assez quoi
alors on dit a toujours touré cheikh
amine tv merci de cet ouvrage deux
échecs roigé cinq tours à schwyz ou 17,3
c48 dame tout reprend 1,8 fou prend 8,3
prend ces trois news alors bobby fischer
une nouvelle fois qu'ils cèdent il nous
dit e7 tourage deux échecs fourrage
trois tours eux deux ces quatre échecs
point d'exclamation héros apprend ckt
wisher même erreur je te fait roi des
quatre et je vais te faire tout
reprendre 7 au prochain et tu vas perdre
donc eu sept tours h2 j'aime bien cette
idée de fouet fois h3 donc fois je trois
tours 2 mais peut-être qu'on perd alors
est-ce que ça perd ou pas ou est ce
qu'on peut faire un truc après tours 2
c'est tendu
à vous souffrez les tontons vous
souffrez 1 alors que cet ouvrage de roy
boostera suite fou 17.8 oui mais ça fait
que nul mais ce qu'on peut gagner
on voit pas mal sourit à main soit par
la souris
c'est bizarre on est censé voir ma
souris
tu revends désolé ah ok on voit ma
souris ça y est merci d'avoir écrit un
set de best
ok bobby fischer à la bonne ligne
recettes tourage de foisches 3 pour
empêcher que la touraine en a je suis
tout re de manants passé 4 qui perd à
cause de roide et 4 mais fou j'ai deux
échecs tour pranger de impossible à
cause de huit dames roi c4est fouet f1
eh ben on a mis le temps ça minutes en
les tontons 1
va tout le monde a compris ce qu on a
ramé ramé ramé là enfin c'est s est elle
enfin fou et en sueur quoi dans le chatt
là je pensais qu'on n'y arriverait pas
merci bobby fischer 2 concentre toi plus
moi plus précis dans ton calcul c'est
pas mal tu calcules pas mal mais tu tu
fais pas assez d'arbres chez rose n95
qui lui dit j'ai du mal à saisir ce
qu'on cherche à faire
en fait quand ses traits au blanc
normalement là tu as et très haut blanc
on cherche à faire gagner les blancs
mais le truc c'est que l'on cherche les
meilleures défenses pour les noirs aussi
c'est que générallement tu as juste
combien a bien expliqué affi rosen et
puis aux autres qui peuvent se poser la
même question le problème des joueurs
généralement des personnes quand ils
résolvent des exercices tactiques
c'est vrai qu'ils font jouer des coups
de merde à l'adversaire il cherche pas
les meilleures défenses et en partie
alors là ça marche parce que tu sens
quel est le bon coup et puis tu vas
trouver mais en partie en fait ça va pas
marcher
et en plus d'apprendre à chercher les
meilleures défenses ça te permet de
fouiller et 2
mais de faire des coups de fouine quoi
pour réussir à défendre un peu comme ce
que je fais généralement
ok exercices suivants aux quêteurs
points 4 des points 4 fois m6 tour h4 ok
on a tout reprend 1,4 puis on prend 1,4
fois m6 échec lors ovation la bande
détourage 80 à l'exercice suivant
alors très haut noir sur son site
allemand la cata solution pour les
blancs
bon
je sais ce que je ferai ou pas
non mais ok je comprends l'idée mais
ok je sais ce que je ferai je vous
laisse chercher
alors sur fouet f3 les tontons l'idée
des blancs c'est de vous faire [ __ ] g6
alors ok fou prend f1 je pense que ça
gagne le coût de bobby fischer je suis
même sûr que ça gagne et c'est ce que je
ferai en partie soit pas du tout comment
défend le piège pense que c'est de
laisser le fou sur la grande diagonale
et de se prendre ou g6 le deuxième truc
auquel je pensais c'était dame b 6 pour
essayer de fouiner mais je risquerais
pas en partie un truc comme ça
parmi eux en copie rios reddan pranger
ces trois projets de nan je pense qu'il
faut enfin le coup et d'un français et
que fouet 3 c'est un piège à cause de
fous j'ai 6 donc on va partir sur la
pelouse de bobby fischer ouais tout le
monde a compris le piège ou pas alors
faut casser empêcher pas fou j'ai 6 ans
fait il pouvait quand même te faire
bouger si tu es toute façon pas faire
tout reprendre les six on peut regarder
un mais tu es fou et qu'avec le truc ce
qui te fait quand même fou j'ai 6 ou
même fou g4 sur foucades d'ailleurs
encore plus fort
eilat et peut-être même mal puisqu'ils
masqué prend le cadre du coup
et sur foued 3 c'est fou j'ai six ou
dame prend g7 aussi un peut-être ça
aussi un très fort et les blancs ont
tous quoi donc très fort foot.fr forces
propres en f1 et dames français finit
gros avantages matériels suivants ou là
puisque c'est que ce coup de merde c'est
ça y'a personne qui joue b6 copains
c'est juste moche quoi
combi qui c'est dur quand tu viens de
commencer vraiment je sais je sais c'est
dur ça prend du temps
elle cherche au sky prend note qu'elle
prend des cinq es14 à mon avis n'est ya
deux coups qui gagne mais je pense
qu'elle prend des 5 et e4 ça gagne juste
une pièce net mais bécistes raymond v 1
allez on va partir pour ça
ok
allez celui-là très haut blanc là encore
un pareil même conseil que depuis tout à
l'heure un coup comme cavani h5
honnêtement j'aurais pas recommandée
parce qu'il ya tellement de trucs
emprise
enfin ça sent pas bon quoi tu tues tu
mets des trucs en prit cette fin
ok faut prendre cet échec fut la fin
avec tout le monde donc en fait ils
attaquent notre dame avec son cavalier
mais il a sa dame emprise en des huit
dont ce qu'on va faire ce qu'il a fait à
fourrage cet échec on va ramener son
rang h7 comme ça on va pouvoir faire dam
des trois échecs on va décaler notre
dame et maintenant on va prendre sa dame
mais il ya plus notre dame en prison
qu'on va gagner une dame breil sur roya
schwyzois y avait d'un match 4
ok suivant assez joli ça ça c'est joli
un grand classique une nouvelle fois
mais joli et surtout avec saint joseph
sainte non bêtement
ok max nash qui a le bon coup d'un match
6 l'idée c'est surtout on prend à
fiscalité propre fils matt je vous
montrais parce que c'était joli pour
ceux qui n'ont pas pu voir c'est un joli
thème de mad classiques qui passent si
vous le connaissez ou pas mais c'est du
grand classique
madame vous savez si cela est peut-être
ça mais ça devait perdre du maïs ou y
mamie non c'est vrai qu'on aurait dû le
voir tu as raison
suivant carrier g4
par les assureurs enfin
trésors qu'il ya un esprit c'est un truc
très pragmatique mais je pense que c'est
bon
ouais je sais ce que j'aurais joué
alors on nous propose cavaliers pros f3
admettons tourcoing f3 tourache un échec
croit prend h1 damage 5 mais bon roi g1
et ya rien le problème c'est que ce fait
qu'il est pro f 3 tours point f3 damas
cinq à je fais roi et fin il ya pas mal
ce que sur damas charge aux réfugiés et
je répète sur cavaliers f3 tour f3
tourache un roi chain damage 5 je fais
rien n'y a rien en fait
ah ok bien joué à mine on commence par
damage 5
du coup en fait il n'a pas le temps de
sortir le roi parce que sur n'importe
quel con fait cavalier premiers froids
et d'un machin maths et il n'a pas le
temps de faire tourner un clip en f3 et
femmes ce qui à la dame en d2 qui traîne
la case h2 grauby elle était contrôlée
par le cavalier g4 qui contrôlait la
case lecavalier hengy cathy contrôler la
case age 2
et quand bien même tu ferais damage deux
échecs croit f1 d'amasha à fougères
donc ça marcherait pas pour te montrer
quand bien même je te ferai pas cavalier
prend dormir meyrin en fait tu vas tu
pas ok suivant où la parler
joli
c'est pas grave robbie ça va venir ça va
venir tonton à force d'en faire ça à
venir
très haut noir
par amine d'une cavalière quatre années
donc je fasse tour c1
jur cavalière qu'as tu fait tour c'est
un bon dix cavaliers à f 4g prend 1 500
kg pour l'instant je fais roi f5 bobby
fischer 2 paragraphe je prends h 5 tours
f3 ok donc un relief 4 puis on croit h5
et la très importante et surtout
paroisse proche 5,6 à tour h7 matt de
l'escalier mayroy f5 un petit quand même
conseil important pour lui fischer un tu
regardes trop laid c'est vraiment trop
linéaire dans ta manière de calculer
je sais que tu calcules bien et tu
calcules tu est mieux que des gens qui
ont trouvé la réponse ou quoi mais je
veux dire que tu es trop tu es trop
directe en fait tu prends pas le temps
de tu vois je dire attends j'ai
peut-être autre chose à faire tu vas
trop trop en ligne droite mais pas
causés chaque cessé d arbres faut
réussir à être à être flexible
on n'a pas trop le choix
mats et dalit mais justement peut-être
parfois un peu ralentir pour mieux
accélérer comme un fou
je me caille décision revient à voir
quelques quelques variantes du cailly
prend à cette eau si j'ai un regard plus
de variantes
jetez un oeil sur sur l'autre chat
alors sur eux cette parole je vais quand
même te faire tout reprend ainsi ses
chèques intermédiaire ça fait le savoir
alors bobby fischer dans la fin de ta
variante quand tu fais cavaliers à sept
rois des huit fou j'ai s'accroît 8 quand
tu fais d'alger six échecs tadam est
cloué c'est interdit
donc la bonne réponse et là des pontes
de tchekhov ses cavaliers des 6es chaque
cil roi avancer c'est tout en baies
vitrées ont fait cavaliers f cet échec
et cavaliers prend la fuite et on sauve
notre dame et s'il était venu en des 8
bah en fait on a fêté les fèves tard
elle est surtout au premier set on
aurait fait d'armes prend 1,28 et
apprendre aurait pris la vo ket suivant
très haut blanc
tarif n'est une tour francis dame prend
1,5 mais c'est pas fini 1
si à faire rage et si c'est ça continue
alors tout reprend ses six tours
processes dame prend 1,5 rouages et six
fours b1 f5
mais je suis pas sûr que vous aller
mater le problème bobby fischer c'est
que si tu fait tour à tour ses six tours
ces six dames saint-croix jécistes ours
damas ici va te faire tour pro f 6
on dit préfère dame hcc il faut calculer
les mecs moi je n'ai pas le temps de
répondre à vos trucs là du coup j'ai
sais pas j'ai pas calculer j'ai par un
calcul encore
mais sur des matches si ça va faire bref
ça qui a fait 3e set j'imagine
aline de beaune fischer c'est pas fini
d'ailleurs processus d'un problème c'est
que c'est tentant mais faut vraiment
calculé jusqu'au bout moi je n'arrive
pas par exemple à feuillage suis pas
j'ai le cerveau qui est largement
ralenti
mais je n'ai que ça doit fonctionner
j'arrive pas à trouver
sur d'alger cet échec à la fin de façon
il va pas faire froid ici il va aller il
va aller en h5 avec son roi et sur oise
5 g 4 bobby fischer ya dame pranger 4
quand le roi y en a cinq
j'ai pas j'arrive pas à faire marcher ce
truc
à ses urines fitch s vc laon on a parlé
pas tout à leur tour ces six tours ces
six dames machin roigé ici se fout bien
et f5 brousse du sida match 8 pouces de
carrick d'un match 8 peut-être un c'est
pas bête un match rythmé bon au pire y
fait roi recettes
pour le moment on trouve rien
honnêtement pour le moment trouvé à rien
j'arrive pas usuel mater là bas
à leucate j'ai pensé aussi
ce retour des 1 le problème c'est qu'il
ya dame prend des airs
cryptage qui me repose tout reprend ses
six tours france ait six vous prend 1,5
et sur oise 7
j'imagine qu'il veut faire d'alger cinq
rois f8 fou j'ai cet échec 3g 8go f6
échec et dames g7 alors ça peut-être ça
marche donc tour ses six tours ces six
fours ou 5 3e set s'efforçait dame j'ai
cinq échecs sur f6 sur adam g7 et on va
mater et donc ça marche normalement
deuxième question pour ces systèmes
france et 6
du coup c'est une autre question
mais sur dame prend c'est ici s'il doit
y avoir dame prend 1,5
moi j'ai six fours b1 échec vous même
les trucs avec dams et c'est tgca
doivent marcher à ce moment là ça doit
aller aller on va tenter au look est
donc tout à fait d'armes français 6 pour
éviter la vente de cryptes al manar
comment on fait
c'est pas encore tout à fait fini
c'est pas tout à fait pareil parce que
sur fou prend 1,5 3,7 dame g5 y aura roi
17 alors dame prend 5,3 g et six fours
b1 droit à six dames j'essaie 3,5 qui
s'échappe
j'ai quatre rois h4
foued 6 3 3 damages 6 aura pranger
quatre dames f4 3,5 et dames g5 maths ça
doit aller
il va pas plus loin mais ça devait
fonctionner comme ça
ça j'ai fonctionné comme ça
à quelque chose près ok suivant n'était
pas mal celui-là monsieur est marrant
quoique
très haut noir
très haut noir alors est-ce que j'ai des
réponses dans le chat alors tour d un
échec croit le 2 et d'amd 8
exact c'est important de faire dame des
8es pas tour des miss que ce retour des
8 je pense qu'il a poussé 1
tout retour des 1 le fou peut pas
prendre la dame reste en prise et là
j'ai même que sur tour des huit il a
poussé un et bizarrement ça a pas l'air
de conclure tout cas j'ai cette
impression
alors que dan des 8 est beaucoup plus
fort je crois quoi que sur d'amd vitia
fougue 4 à calculer encore c'est pas
fini peut-être meilleur tour des huit
tours de 8 pouces et un c'est pas tout à
fait fini encore cette histoire
d'amener de feu cas restants prise
savoir gagner à ces dames des 8 c sur
ces dames des huit que quand il va
s'échapper avec le fou on pourra faire
tour des deux dames f6 mat
j'espère que vous avez vu on va passer
au suivant va essayer d un petit peu
avancé
à ces jeux issa
ça c'est très joli l'ombre de katie
salut je viens d'arriver j'ai raté
beaucoup bataillé trois quarts d'heure
mais non pas spécialement
je cherche il ya tout eu trouver d'amd
huy dong wei fischer qui est pas mal
dans le qui a plus de mal dans les
variantes à calculer mais qui est pas
mal dans les petites variantes courte
quoi parce que d'amd 8 pas mal en fait
ça à menace la tour c 7 et du coup sur
coup franc juridiques ont fait d'armes
français 7 et on attaque la tourbe et si
c'est le food et 4s qui était pas mal en
fait avec d'amd 8
c'est que s'ils voulaient défendre par
tour cc6 qui semblait marche à première
vue il y avait foule prend prise est
prise en b 6 passes pas ça évidemment et
du coup là cette menace a été pénible et
surtour c6 fou prend pas mal un joli
géométrie ok suivant
marla ça pue 1 ou pas ou pas
wilshere qui a du mal avec les longues
jambes ça se voit tu as du mal quand ça
se coupe feu tu t'entraînes a calculé
que tu as plus de tactique comme on fait
maintenant en fait c'est un excellent
exercice pour toi salut à baulou 1999
alors nous gâchent dit roy problème
devient qu'il faut calculer kg cadre
d'un projet cinq faux calcul est là les
tontons à s'arrête pas là les variantes
ces tactiques sait pour quel niveau je
sais pas bleu bouffonne life sciences a
invoqué cristal qui a trouvé les rois
prend f2 on le laisse faire sa tactique
a été éjecté à 3 g iii on le laisse
faire dame pranger 5
c'est une fois qui fait d'armes frangé
sac fais ta main quatre échecs et on
encaisse g4 hockey suivant
les positions que j'aurais jamais sur
l'échiquier ça c'est complètement
ridicule pour les blancs
sur la pollution fait j'ai beaucoup de
mal à calculer ce que ça me parait
spatiale comme position
du coup je souffre dans ces trucs là
c'est vraiment spécial quand j'aurai
jamais cette position sur l'échiquier
c'est impossible
le mic avec les blancs est trop nul
on y croise bref deux dames 1 j'ai un
échec
toile f1 d'alger 3 ouais ça doit gagner
tout doit gagner enfin un truc c'est que
moi je vois m dames 3 h 3 quoi mais bon
d'un branchement est peut-être non mais
je sais pas mais c'est cette position
j'ai vraiment du mal on va faire
confiance à vos vies on fait ce qu'on
fait confiance à bobby charles hey mec
là j'ai la flemme de calculer ce truc là
mais ça en partie je trouve quoi comment
gagner mais sur l'exercie j'ai
énormément de mal
allez on fait confiance bien jeux wii
fischer n'en faut à temps il me faut
mais il me donne plus quatre points elo
or c'était quoi la réponse au québec
ramq est là s'est amusé quoi dame prend
h4 sava russie 1 c'est gagnant aussi un
juste dame g5 eu près si on avez la
flemme
bon il nous a quand même donné des
points même on nous met en faut mais non
le compte juste à ça c'est marrant ça
j'aime bien comme tactique c'est des
trucs qui peuvent arriver en partie ok
j'ai trouvé ou pas
pas si j'ai trouvé pas si simple
bon ok le truc c'est que la rente qu'on
a gagné c'est comme gagnant à l'audimat
de l'escalier mais c'est pas forcément
si simple que tour à 6,3 baissera 17
tours b c à 3 c 8
comment on fait après
ensuite tour g7
a kara j'ai plein de questions et
première question c'est tout reprend à
carcans fait je pense a instruit mais
j'ai peut-être pas trouvé d'ailleurs
il ya plein de questions après tour je
sais tu
ah si j'ai trouvé
il ya plein plein de questions en fait
c'est vrai ces tours g7 web et huit
tours et fils mais même dans sa variante
3 b 8 tours tours f6 je te fais tchekhov
tour ces deux et surtout reif 8 échecs
qui aura tour s'est vite et je couvre
vraiment la personne qui a les bonnes
réponses
vous avez tous compris le thème bon je
vais avancer la position jusqu'ici sur
ce plus facile pour tout le monde de
voir et on va s'arrêter là
n'a pas à tour g7 mais tours b 8 au
niveau l'ol su et au vu de ce fait pour
prendre trois points 8
ce qui est un problème avoue le ou ne
l'avouent pas leur ceinture
alors ce retour g7 je fais roye b 8e
tchekhov et c'est surtout rêve si ce que
je fais tour c'est 8
tous rêvent set je suis roi v8 pareil
tours afp trois v8 les mecs allez on se
bouge un peu le cul là c'est trop mou là
c'est trop mou tours fc 3 v8 faut
calculer aller un peu plus de 2 de nerfs
quoi un peu plus de violence les mecs et
angers 7 heures on avait huit tarifs 6 e
tour ces deux tours f7 roye b 8 tout
réussi ce tour c'est de pareilles ok
sauf qu'ils trouvent enfin vous faire
ton g7 et suroît v8 tourbe et 6 échecs
très important maintenant leroy obligé
d'aller ont sévi tout en 8es maintenant
foot ou rêve 6 et la différence et qui
peut plus couvrir merci sauge 49
tu m'as sauvé j'en pouvais plus quoi
important ces petits trucs
allez faut un peu plus de vitesse les
mecs à un peu plus de vitesse et de
rigueur allez on continue et surtout
rejet cette rage et 3a
turfoo les trois tours à huit matches
bêtement
et surtout reprend à 4 tours et fils
ok
suivant
qui sait ce type quoi de quel droit il
nous prend ce pion
mme étonnant
alors on propose fous ces 8es j'aime
beaucoup ce coût ce que georges et
prenait 4 d'un match 4 il va rien à voir
on va se prendre une fourchette mais fou
ces huit très bien joué on menace fou
prend bessette là avec ses 5 il empêche
tout prend bessette qui gagnaient la
tour en fait j'ai pris un f4 et on gagne
ok j'ai envie de dire
ne se fait pas très longtemps là
on va le faire rapidement puisque la
flemme de calculer ok juste là c'est la
question en fait est ce qu'on fait
d'amener 3 ou dame g4 c'est toujours une
question épineuse ça
alors d'alger et 4 l'élan probablement
faire f 5
mais aussi h4 qui est jouable et qui est
peut-être plus fort ici
le premier truc que vous regardez 60 dam
des trois dames g4 si ça marche pas trop
on peut regarder aussi h4 là je pense
cash 4 c'est plus fort en l'état actuel
des choses mais il est vrai qu'on
regarde ces dames détroit et d'amitié 4
si ça marche pas on passe à autre chose
en tout cas je lui en prit le premier
truc à calculer ces dames g4 f5
puis on prend un point f6 et là ça
suffit pas dams et 2 je pense f5 aussi
je préfère h4 perso enfin l'eau va
essayer et comme ça va donc faire h5
les angevins 15.6 et gay prend des huit
hockey un problème bobby fischer c'est
qu'après dame g45 puis on prend ainsi 3
points fils gamal et h70 f7 même s'ils
récupèrent la tour comme tu as donné une
pièce c'est pas top top
bon je vois qu'un coup perso mais je
sais pas est ce que je me trompe
lorsqu'il ya des neuf quelques huées
d'un emprunt
vous êtes en échec car les tontons donc
je voulais faire dame c3 ça va être
tendu quoi
or kebede deux dames prend un faux h3
qui menacent m'attendais 7 et noir ont
pas le temps de perdre la dame au québec
2 doit sauver le flou c5 et ça doit
gagner à laisse avec qui et bd 2 et x h
3 on peut pas faire dans l'esprit un ya
pas un truc bojan fou prend décès trois
des huit français 6 3 et 8 dames 17 noms
allez on est obligés de faire mouche
ça c'est un grand classique aussi ou pas
c'est joli ça oh ouais ça c'est super
classe
sur elle est super classe
je laisse un peu réfléchir
alors quitte à l'epad tout ça fait
jusque tour d un échec roy h2 d'anne
decis g3 puis on prend g3 je fais
papillon proche des 3 jeux férois g2 je
vais pas je vais pas vous prendre en g3
les mecs un jeu où faire rager 2 une
nouvelle fois mêmes défauts que souvent
trop linéaire vous réfléchissez pas aux
alternatives pas assez
ce que j'ai trois pions point je crois
en rage et de personne ne va vous
reprendre un salut à sa place
on est les noirs l'échiquier tournée non
envers les blancs
ok talent qu'a trouvé qu'on va faire
tourner un échec qui vont faire rage
devrait faire d'anne decis ils vont
faire g3 donc très important d'être venu
en d6 parce qu'après pions prendre tu
peux pas reprendre du plus obscur et
d'amd 2 et là du coup on va sacrifier la
tout ranger 1ère dame d1 dames f3 dame
f2 et d'un match de maths gagner ok
allez suivant
chat c'était joli
crystal qui calcule très bien
moi je commence à ralentir la poêle
fatigués keita tu vas trouver plus vite
que moi ma main et c'est tant mieux
ethan qui dit dans la set ça ok mais
damas est ya plein de questions un jet
asus 3g 8 c'est une question mais on
rajoute peut-être tourage 7 mai damas 7
tours 7
je connaissais 3g 8 je pense courage ça
a été en double sur la 7ème et damas
sept tours 7
c'est la question que je me pose est
est-ce qu'on peut faire tout rage suite
damas huit
je pense que c'est ça en plus
mais c'est compliqué parce que damas est
aussi d'amener cette dame prend v6 qui
est prend bien turaci je vois pas ce que
vous menacer les mecs turaci sky prend
bien
damas a toujours cette dame à 8 mai y
aurait au f-16 et toi je suis toi
damages suite même peut-être wes que sur
trouver une armée c'est d'amasser damas
cette course est en fait tu tues vers
damas huit tours à la tour à tour b 8
tours h8 wife cette tour prend b8 non
mais ça va je suis sûr que ces dames à 7
un dash-8 gagne la tour alors damas je
suis 3e cet ouvrage c'est trois des huit
je suis quasi sûr que ces dames à 7
mesdames et mesdames prend b6 bêtement
non prise b1 est prise g6 et ça doit
aller il doit y avoir un match on va
prendre la tour il va prendre b1
ouais donc le truc c'est que à mens je
vais pas mettre faire
et surtout recettes et à tous qu'il ya
une tour à lui d'ailleurs leur nid donne
plus fort mais dans ma vie ça suffit
large au sein sur wave 7 doit pouvoir
faire tout rage cette dame c'est 8 mai
tour h8 aussi c'est juste bien en fait
tu azam g8 mat
puis mon budget de monter et tu as par
materi des trucs comme ça quoi mais ça
ce sens là une fois que le fou il peut
arriver angers si ça sent que ça maths
et sur damas huit tours b 8i la tourache
8 es tu vas te faire enfiler à les
suivants
moi je lis ça allait on laisse ses
joueurs un peu moins fort trouver
peut-être sa jeune zoophilie c'est un
peu trop haut niveau rêve va essayer que
je fasse un compte avec un plus petits
lots
il ya un math force est là les mecs
m'attend 3 il ya un match en trois les
mecs
car je sais pas si ça marche de ce côté
là je vous prends l'accession en pro f 6
d'amd 6,3 à 6,8 tour huit matches s'est
racheté comme ça aurait d'ailleurs mais
bon surtout price ici peut faire froid
ces huit meilleurs atours 8 quand même
autour on voit ces sept
je pense que lors de coups le plus juste
ces dames b6 sa force froissé huit tours
sa force cavaliers prend et dames des
mythes maths c'est l'ordre le plus clean
parce que surtout problème si ça donne
plus d'options alors c'est complètement
gagnant aussi un art mais c'est moins de
manga niant annoncé pas complètement
gagnant lors des jeux dit roy c7 et il
te dit c'est chaud mais l'autre est plus
d'am dam d'un v6 3,8 d'amd 8 est juste
complètement fort c'est quoi
geoffroy fils et sur échec ah oui ça
menaces oui tu as toujours d'alger de
maths qui menacent oui évidemment à les
suivants
bon ce que je pense que je suis ce que
j'aurais fait un jeu pas sur sûr encore
tu pas complètement sûr
je suis pas complètement sûr donc aux
dames j'ai un ami à eux deux
aussi très fin il ya plein de trucs
possibles
c'est alphonse tous rêvent de comment
hartwell 2 c à c ur et sa menace dame g1
donc sa force eurois c1
c'est pas sûr c'est imparable parce que
roy c1
mais l'étude de fer damien roy deux
tours f2 aura des trois d'emprunt ça me
paraît complètement finie aussi un
on tournait la tête dam des trois
options ni dans le chat par écouter
honnêtement ce serait pas cassé la tête
j'aurais fait pareil que l'intérêt
j'avais dame j'ai un roi 2 tous rêvent
de roi des trois est empreint d'un bloc
et on va pas être des cônes en quoi va
pas se casser la tête
j'ai plus qui a dit ça dans le chat mais
c'est beaucoup plus simple quand pas se
casser les couilles à faire tous rêvent
de données nettement c'est plus simple
de faire ça parfait
les pièces emprise de partout
honnêtement j'aurais pris la fuite parce
que je me serais dit que j'aurais
d'armes à sept derrière
honnêtement j'aurais fait qu'est point
f8 bac idée de faire d'un match 7 damage
fuite maths à tout moment et genre
souquet pour les futurs greffés tour
prend b3 je fais dame prend d'un match
cet échec je l'aï fait roi f8
je fais juste apprend b3 à ce moment là
non je commence par damage suite et je
fais à prend b3 après et sur quels
points wifi de fou prend h2 je fais
juste 3 h un je m'en fous pareils je
prends en fuite
et ouais c'est trop fort c'est un match
c'est à la suite
le truc c'est que si on fait tout bessin
tourbe et 5 va sûrement faire fou prend
h23 bouge il faut prendre 17 et en fait
c'est ce qu'on fait en perdant
alors qu'avec mon truc
c'est hyper fort comme menace
hyper fort ça comme menace
suivant
ok là c'est on va faire la simplicité
dans celui-là je pense à
ou pas
pas d'ailleurs
on va faire un super simplicité et comme
dit amèrement talent vocal faire corps
unis bobby fischer tout prendre h6 et on
va faire f 6 seule caste dame g71 toutes
les autres cases étaient occupés on
prend la dame
en créant prend la dame oui a pas de
piège utilisé c'est quoi ce truc là ok
suivant pour là
bon
allez on va laisser les joueurs un peu
moins fort trouver suit la turquie avait
pas adam g 5 c'était pas ma taille
réussissent encore aller au blanc four
prouver s'il ya plusieurs options et
adam prochain qui a pu en prendre et 6
offre un v6 2.5 pouces et 5 mat
marc sur dame française jeanne resort
sûr il va te faire voir france et 7
après fouet f4 il fera roi bessette je
pense pas que tu mates vous-même roi des
huit peut-être il va s'échapper il a
trop de cases avec son ou encore
mais c'est une bonne idée au-delà de ça
ok la réponse est franc b6 sur dame
prend sur dame prend et afu ses cinq
matches
et sur qui on prend il ya tout reprend
3,7 et damas cinq matches suivants
qu'est ce que c'est que ça en fait la
gela jeu là je comprends pas je consorts
du mal à calculer mais là soit c'est moi
qui ai une association sont va le
résoudre direct en fait fin on va
laisser les gens recherchés mais là y'a
un truc qui m'échappe
ah ok j'ai compris ce qui m'échappait
hockey d'un match pas à faire voyager un
peu plus rien mais c'est fini ce que roy
d'arrache-pied pas faire broyer faire
rager 1
et sur dame g4 après il fera fou j'ai de
ces dames g4 direct probablement et
dames g3 matt gmail c'est juste dams et
4 dames g3 mais ok j'ai compris le piège
l'idée section d'un match 3 s'était pas
aidé saccani pas direct
alors ici qu'est ce que c'est que ça
qu'est ce que c'est que ça
bizarre ce position
qui est un truc team tente mais j'suis
pas sauf ce soit ça d'un médecin système
c8 vrai c'est ce qui me tente aussi sol
je raconte yannick pons d'amel cinq
tours j'ai 4 way to me tente en fait là
les cinq tours du cat ceux ci traite
entend bien faire d'un match 3 j'imagine
là dessus avec pour idée sur tourcoing
cadre defferre d'impro f5
dans cinq de ses huit ça rend ce que
j'aurais fait en première intention
la belle salle à manger trois dames h4
sa mort est quand même un peu fait chier
je suis pas cette dame c'est 8 après un
gp palais ont résulté d'un médecin glam
c8 on va finir un peu en dilettante
j'ai la flemme
jusqu'à c'est ce que je pensais et là
comme en ont conclu
c'est peut-être dame fc3a je suis dame
8,3 g7 f7 juste j'étais le tour au cas
du charpentier et donc à ce que je suis
en train de faire c'est exactement ce
qu'il faut pas faire c'est à dire ne pas
calculer
ok la france est ce que je pensais à et
non indifférence section dame c8
j'hésitais hyérois h5 le bouton like we
joaillier les gens sales usa bouffonne
live merci à toi ciao ciao
j'espère que ça t'a plu les exercices
tactiques à une finale ça j'aime bien
ok c'est hyper simple
non
pas si simple
enfin
la greffe
on nous propose attend un transfuge et
2e deux tours f2 mefou g2e de tous
rêvent de il y aura droit à 2 3 et
paroisse les uns et on nous propose un
godbert qui nous propose fois fils un
carrefour f 5 e 2 pour toile de roy 3
sur le même problème
rose fouet ce 5e deux tours c'est un est
sur eux en dame
pour ce tour f si ce retour ercis peu
d'eux
en dames et tour des trois matchs au
caire est un truc qui peut marcher ses
tours f3e de fouet fin et c'est ça c'est
joli
et tour de trois matchs je lis suit la
jolie suivant
ok venu en bouffe tempo on s'en fout
ok maintenant le défonce on fait
peut-être un petit fond f4 non
- désolé j'avais envie d'en faire un
move it s sinon je m'endormais un peu
basse et un hic et j'ai cinq tempo et
abandon ok
qu'est ce que c'est que ça
ok bah je laisse un petit peu chercher
de nouveau à l'art watches damev six
mois est fait autour des 8
merci ça a l'air sympa tâche mandat même
si pour g6 damas depuis trois projets 5
f 4 échecs 3,5 contre échec le poil de
francs des cats et d'un f6 perpète sua
fairway huit thèmes des huits 3g cette
dame f70 âge qui suit sur quasi et bien
je suis trois projets cinq suivants
non
comment vous faites
celui théorique finale gagné encore
comment tu fais et c'est ce qui fait
tout reprend douze tours prend tout le
monde se trompe
bah vous avez tous perdu ce que ça gagne
pas du tout c'est le gros piège finale
théorique nul à yahya yahya et comment
faut que vous travaillez au final
comment vous êtes mauvais en finale
quand même
avant ce qu'il soit à l'envers ou soit
pas un truc je pense juste faire ou à
ces quatre là tu es ici c'est ton
affaire tour échec et on va lui bouffer
le pion non on se prend à perpète à la
con moi j'ai la flemme de calculer je
vais vous montrer comment vous avez mais
comment vous êtes comment vous êtes en
sueur prise prises trois c4 ou ivo
position je te fait roi bessette
tu me fais roi prend je devais roi b6
news une petite news
olalala sueur dans le chat en le chat en
sueur le chat en pls de niveau 10 quoi
normes et les mecs si vous connaissez
pas vos final les plus basiques qu'on
voulait qu'on avance quoi alors la sueur
la sueur dans le chat la pls à la pls au
sérieux ça me fait flipper kwata
désabonner et mecs soient brouillés
depuis deux ans trois ans la chaîne
vitry même quatre ans ou 5
ils sont très heureux oui je connais mes
finales et boum la finale de pions
basique
mais ça même bourré après deux
bouteilles de vodka tu dois pas le faire
toi tu dois connaître la pls dans le
chatt râler mais qui sont dit on et 1800
2000 on sait jouer aux échecs et là tout
d'un coup alors comment va falloir aller
bosser
il est 9h30 donc c'est la fin du tri on
va finir là-dessus va finir sur un faut
bosser ces finales parce que là c'est la
cata les mecs la catastrophe
3 je suis pas content je suis pas
content je suis pas content depuis tant
qu'on se connaît recommencer à se faire
tout petit sur le tchat
il n'y a plus un mot là là c'est ya plus
un moyen plus personne n'y amis ont su à
quoi ils chialent quoi trolamine en plus
c'est sur le discorde amine quoi aulas
pls la pls pour amin
ce rôle là
à l'époque je suis triste pour moi et je
vous en juin dernier les mecs
oh là là c'est encore une finale rolala
vous jouez votre vie là dessus les
feuilles vous jouez votre vie si vous la
trouvez pas celle là on est malin si
vous la trouvez pas celle-là je sais pas
comment on va faire
pas si dur que ça 3-4-3 bessette
bouger de roye b 8 à 6 au refuge et de
il te fait roi c'est 8
repoussé huit on va pas faire gober ça
on va faire froid prend à cinq tentes
ont poussé 8 roi prend à 5 les parois b5
temps croît à 4,3 bessette comme on joue
après
bon allez je vais vous mettre parce
qu'ici on peut y arriver parce que je me
fasse mieux parce que j'ai eu vraiment
beaucoup de mal à calculer on croit à
caa3 bessette forcella moi j'aurais fait
roi b5 perso j'ai à me faire re 1 dames
je lui faire à 6 échecs il à me faire
rouabeh huit tués lui faire à cet échec
je vais faire roi b16 vais me faire un
message de fer fou j'ai deux il va me
faire voir ces huit je fais dame et la
finale est gagnante à les tontons à les
tontons les tontons on va conclure là
dessus va falloir bosser ces finales
alors bon bah je sais pas vous avez les
master classes vous avez des bouquins
vous avez des cours particuliers
il ya moyen de pouvait parler avec votre
club aussi à moyen de ya moyen de se
débrouiller mais sérieux il va falloir
me bosser tout ça il y avoir un beau
c'est tout ça et là c'est vraiment le
site chaise comme qui a voulu vous
châtié quoi
c'est vraiment le site chien.com qui a
voulu vous châtié en vous mettant de
finale de finale pour finir coup sur
coup quoi je suis vraiment désolé les
mecs je suis vraiment désolé je voulais
pas finir comme ça c'est chasse comme
qui a décidé de vous punir bon ben vous
savez ce que vous avez à faire cette
semaine et rendez vous samedi soir du
coup sur la chaîne bitstream pour pour
la chine que phil cup à partir de 20
heures
ciao ciao